Bun venit înapoi la înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice. Mă numesc John Wattress și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM
Quantum. Aceasta este a 16-a și ultima lecție a seriei, iar subiectul lecției este computația cuantică tolerantă la erori.
Pe parcursul celor trei lecții anterioare, am văzut mai multe exemple de coduri cuantice de corectare a erorilor care pot detecta și ne permit să
corectăm erorile cuantice, atâta timp cât nu sunt prea multe. Dacă vrem să folosim corecția erorilor pentru computația cuantică, totuși, mai există multe
probleme de rezolvat, inclusiv realitatea că gate-urile noastre cuantice, măsurătorile și pregătirile de stare
sunt ele însele susceptibile de a fi imperfecte. Deci, de exemplu, dacă vom efectua corecția erorilor pe unul
sau mai mulți qubiți care au fost codificați folosind un cod cuantic de corectare a erorilor, atunci va trebui să facem asta cu gate-uri și măsurători care la rândul lor
au șansa să nu funcționeze corect. Și asta înseamnă nu doar că nu reușim să detectăm sau să corectăm erorile, ci posibil
și să introducem erori noi. În plus, trebuie să efectuăm și calculele efective care ne interesează, din nou cu gate-uri care nu sunt
perfecte. Și cu siguranță nu ne putem permite să decodificăm informația cuantică pentru a efectua calcule și apoi
să o recodificăm după ce terminăm, deoarece erorile ar putea apărea când protecția unui cod cuantic de corectare a erorilor lipsește.
Asta înseamnă că trebuie să găsim o modalitate de a efectua gate-uri cuantice direct pe qubiții logici care nu rămân niciodată fără
protecția unui cod cuantic de corectare a erorilor. Aceasta este o sarcină dificilă, dar se știe că atâta timp cât nivelul de zgomot
scade sub o anumită valoare prag, este de fapt posibil să efectuezi calcule cuantice arbitrar de mari în mod fiabil folosind hardware zgomotos, cel puțin
în teorie. Și vom discuta acest fapt extrem de important mai târziu în lecție. Iată o scurtă prezentare generală a
lecției. Vom începe cu un model de bază pentru computația cuantică tolerantă la erori, incluzând o scurtă discuție
despre modelele de zgomot, împreună cu o metodologie generală pentru implementarea unui circuit cuantic în mod tolerant
la erori. Vom trece apoi la problema propagării erorilor în circuit-urile cuantice tolerante la erori și cum să
o controlăm. În special, voi discuta implementările transversale de gate-uri care oferă o modalitate foarte simplă de a controla propagarea erorilor.
Deși există o limitare fundamentală care ne împiedică să folosim această metodă
exclusiv. Voi vorbi și despre o metodologie diferită implicând așa-numitele magic states, care oferă o altă cale de a controla propagarea erorilor
în circuit-urile cuantice tolerante la erori. Deși nu este singura metodă cunoscută și, în final, lecția
se încheie cu o discuție destul de sumară a teoremei pragului, la care am făcut aluzie chiar acum un moment.
Această teoremă afirmă că circuit-urile cuantice arbitrar de mari pot fi implementate în mod fiabil atâta timp cât rata de erori a tuturor componentelor
implicate scade sub o anumită valoare prag finită. În general, această valoare prag
depinde de codul de corectare a erorilor pe care îl folosim, precum și de alegerile specifice pe care le facem pentru implementările tolerante la erori ale
gate-urilor cuantice și ale măsurătorilor, dar nu de dimensiunea circuit-ului implementat. Și asta ne oferă un motiv bun să credem că
calculele cuantice la scară largă vor deveni într-o zi realitate. Vom începe prin a discuta un model de bază pentru computația cuantică tolerantă la erori,
care se bazează în mod natural pe circuit-uri cuantice și coduri cuantice de corectare a erorilor. Pentru scopul acestei discuții,
să ne imaginăm că avem un circuit cuantic pe care sperăm să îl implementăm, cum ar fi cel prezentat aici. Acesta se întâmplă să fie
un circuit de teleportare care include pregătirea EBIT-ului. Dar detaliile nu contează cu adevărat pentru această discuție. Și poți imagina că
acesta este orice alt circuit cuantic, posibil un circuit mult mai mare care include pregătiri de stare, operații unitare
și măsurători. Acest circuit reprezintă, desigur, un ideal, iar o implementare
efectivă a lui nu va fi perfectă. Întrebarea firească este ce ar putea merge prost?
Ei bine, sunt destul de multe lucruri care ar putea merge prost. De exemplu, inițializările de stare în general nu vor fi
perfecte. Desigur, gate-urile unitare nu vor fi perfecte și nici
măsurătorile. Și mai mult, qubiții înșiși vor fi susceptibili la zgomot, inclusiv decoerență, în orice moment al
calculului, chiar și când nu se întâmplă nimic cu acești qubiți și ei pur și simplu stochează informație cuantică. Cu alte cuvinte, aproape
orice ar putea merge prost. Există totuși o excepție sau cel puțin aceasta este o presupunere tipică și
anume că orice calcule clasice implicate probabil nu vor fi defectuoase, deoarece în toate scopurile practice
calculele clasice sunt practic perfecte. Deci, de exemplu, dacă rulăm un algoritm clasic de potrivire pentru a
calcula corecții pentru erorile codului de suprafață, nu trebuie cu adevărat să ne îngrijorăm că acest calcul clasic ar putea fi defectuos. Dar orice ce
implică informație cuantică ar putea fi. Desigur, avem nevoie de un model precis prin care putem asocia
probabilități pentru diverse lucruri care ar putea merge prost. Și dacă am vrea, am putea elabora un model la fel de complicat pe cât dorim pentru a reflecta cât mai fidel
ce se întâmplă de fapt în realitate. Dacă modelul este prea complicat, totuși, ar putea fi dificil sau imposibil de lucrat cu el sau de a spune
ceva interesant despre el. Un exemplu foarte simplu de model de zgomot pe care oamenii îl consideră adesea
este modelul de zgomot stocastic independent, în care erorile sau defectele care afectează diferite componente în momente diferite
sau, cu alte cuvinte, locații diferite în circuit sunt independente.
De exemplu, am putea spune că fiecare gate eșuează cu o anumită probabilitate, că bitflip-urile și phaseflip-urile se întâmplă qubiților stocați cu o probabilitate diferită
per unitate de timp și așa mai departe. Dar presupunerea este că nu există nicio corelație între diferite
erori. Acum, ai putea obiecta la acel model pentru că probabil vor exista unele corelații între
erori. De exemplu, există probabil o mică șansă a unei erori catastrofale care șterge toți qubiții deodată.
Sau poate mai probabil, ar putea exista erori care sunt localizate, dar care afectează totuși multiple componente.
Și nimeni nu sugerează altceva. Dar cu toate acestea, acest model reprezintă o bază simplă care în
esență reprezintă ideea că natura este imprevizibilă, dar nu este malițioasă și nu încearcă în mod intenționat
să ruineze calculele cuantice. Există și alte modele de zgomot, mai realiste, care sunt adesea luate în considerare. Și indiferent de
modelul pe care îl alegem, dacă se dovedește că modelul nostru ne conduce pe o cale greșită și aflăm ceva nou despre erorile din
orice sistem cu care lucrăm, putem formula în mod natural și lua în considerare modele de erori diferite. Urmează să aruncăm
o privire la o strategie de bază pentru implementarea circuit-urilor cuantice în mod tolerant la erori. Deci să considerăm un
circuit cuantic logic dat, adică un circuit cuantic ideal pe care suntem interesați să îl rulăm. De exemplu, am putea considera același circuit ca
înainte, care este acum extins puțin mai mult deoarece vom avea nevoie de puțin mai mult spațiu pentru implementarea tolerantă la erori a acestuia. Mai întâi,
WEBVTT
pregătirile de stare, gate-urile unitare și măsurătorile nu vor fi efectuate direct ca gate-uri individuale sau ca
măsurători sau pregătiri de stare pe un singur qubit, ci vor fi efectuate prin așa-numitele gadget-uri, care
pot implica fiecare mai mulți qubiți și mai multe operații. Aici, în această diagramă, am
ilustrat acest lucru desenând căsuțe violet în jurul acestor elemente. Și poți să te gândești la aceste căsuțe violet ca la niște mici circuit-uri sau operații care sunt
etichetate pur și simplu de orice pregătire de stare sau gate pe care intenționăm să o implementăm. În al doilea rând, trebuie să protejăm
qubiții folosind un cod de corectare a erorilor. Deci nu vor fi qubiții logici înșiși cei care conectează aceste diferite gadget-uri, ci gadget-urile acționează pe
qubiții fizici care codifică acești qubiți logici. Și merită subliniat că qubiții logici de care ne pasă
nu sunt niciodată expuși, adică acești qubiți logici își vor petrece întreaga existență fiind protejați de orice
cod cuantic de corectare a erorilor folosim. Și în final, efectuăm corecția erorilor pe qubiții noștri codificați
în mod repetat pe tot parcursul calculului, practic ori de câte ori avem ocazia. Și este extrem de important să facem
asta. Intuitiv vorbind, pe măsură ce apar erori, aleatoriul sau incertitudinea începe să se acumuleze în starea
qubiților noștri și trebuie să lucrăm constant pentru a elimina acest aleatoriu sau entropie. Și asta se întâmplă prin corecția erorilor.
Deci poți să te gândești la acești pași de corecție a erorilor ca la niște mici frigidere logice sau pompe de căldură care
permit qubiților logici să rămână reci pentru ca calculul să funcționeze corect.
Odată ce toate aceste alegeri au fost făcute, adică selecția tuturor gadget-urilor, a codului și presupunând un model de zgomot particular, există o
întrebare fundamentală pe care ni-o putem pune și anume, oare asta ajută cu adevărat? Facem lucrurile mai bune sau
le facem mai rele? Dacă există prea mult zgomot, am putea foarte bine să le înrăutățim,
la fel cum codul Shore de 9 qubiți înrăutățește lucrurile dacă șansa unei erori este prea mare.
Dar dacă zgomotul este sub un anumit prag, atunci toată această muncă suplimentară ne va duce undeva. Și după cum vom discuta spre sfârșitul lecției,
se deschid căi pentru reducerea suplimentară a erorii. În această parte a lecției, vom discuta propagarea erorilor în circuit-urile
cuantice tolerante la erori cu structura de bază pe care tocmai am descris-o. Aceasta se dovedește a fi o
preocupare primară deoarece dacă nu reușim să controlăm propagarea erorilor, erorile vor copleși rapid eforturile noastre de corecție a erorilor.
Dar dacă suntem capabili să controlăm propagarea erorilor, atunci codul nostru va avea o șansă mult mai mare
de a ține pasul astfel încât erorile să poată fi corectate la o rată suficient de mare pentru a permite calculelor noastre să
funcționeze. Punctul de plecare pentru această discuție este realizarea că gate-urile cu doi qubiți sau gate-urile cu mai mulți qubiți, mai
general, pot propaga erori chiar și când funcționează corect.
De exemplu, consideră un gate C not. Și presupune că o eroare X apare pe qubit-ul de control înainte ca gate-ul C not să fie
efectuat. Ei bine, o eroare X funcționează exact ca un gate X. Și constatăm că
circuit-ul din stânga este echivalent cu cel din dreapta unde erorile X apar pe ambii qubiți după C
not. Aceasta este o propagare a erorilor deoarece localizarea nefericită a erorii X din stânga o transformă efectiv
în două erori X pe dreapta. Și nu vom putea evita asta niciodată. Atâta timp cât folosim gate-uri C not, există întotdeauna
o șansă ca o eroare X să apară pe qubit-ul de control chiar înainte de acesta, care se propagă apoi în două erori X
după. Dar, după cum vom vedea, atâta timp cât luăm măsuri pentru a limita daunele pe care le provoacă, va fi bine. Apropo,
același fenomen apare când avem o eroare Z pe qubit-ul țintă chiar înainte de un C not. Și am discutat asta
mai devreme și poți verifica aceste egalități pur și simplu efectuând înmulțirile sau le poți verifica folosind
Qiskit. Concluzia este că în ambele cazuri, asta va cauza erori corelate pe mai mulți qubiți. Și desigur
nu trebuie să uităm că gate-urile C not înseși ar putea fi defectuoase, ceea ce poate provoca de asemenea erori corelate.
Adăugând la îngrijorarea noastră, gate-urile cu doi qubiți ulterioare ar putea propaga și mai departe aceste erori.
De exemplu, dacă avem trei gate-uri C not ca acestea, exact cum găsim atunci când măsurăm generatoarele X stabilizator, de exemplu, atunci o eroare unică poate
să se propage rapid pe mai mulți qubiți. Și dacă se întâmplă asta în interiorul unui singur bloc de cod, de exemplu, adică un grup de
qubiți care împreună codifică un qubit logic, orice cod de corectare a erorilor am ales nu va sta
o șansă pentru că codurile sunt concepute să corecteze erori cu greutate mică, nu erori cu greutate mare ca aceasta.
Și deci acesta este un lucru pe care trebuie să îl avem în vedere în prim-plan, de fapt, când ne gândim la gadget-uri și la
pașii de corecție a erorilor în circuit-urile cuantice tolerante la erori. Cea mai simplă metodă cunoscută pentru a atenua propagarea erorilor în circuit-urile
cuantice tolerante la erori este să implementezi gate-urile transversal, și voi explica ce înseamnă asta
imediat. Deci să păstrăm figura implementării noastre tolerante la erori pe ecran doar ca un ajutor vizual.
Ideea este că pentru unele coduri cuantice de corectare a erorilor, anumite gate-uri pot fi implementate transversal, ceea ce
înseamnă implementarea lor folosind gadget-uri care sunt produse tensoriale ale operațiilor, unde fiecare operație acționează doar pe un
singur qubit din fiecare bloc de cod. Cel mai ușor de explicat este prin exemple. Primul și
cel mai simplu exemplu este implementările transversale ale operatorilor Pauli.
Ideea este că vrem să construim gadget-uri pentru fiecare dintre gate-urile din circuit-ul nostru. Și în toate cazurile, acele gadget-uri
operează pe blocuri de cod, ca cele pe care le vedem pentru gate-urile X și Z la sfârșitul circuit-ului nostru de teleportare. Desigur, nu
putem decodifica, aplica un gate Pauli și apoi recodifica, deoarece asta ar lăsa un qubit logic neprotejat și erorile
s-ar putea propaga în interiorul blocului de cod ca urmare a recodificării.
Din fericire, nu trebuie să facem asta atâta timp cât folosim un cod stabilizator, deoarece fiecare cod stabilizator permite ca operațiile
Pauli să fie aplicate direct pe qubiții noștri logici. Și de fapt, putem face asta cu un produs tensorial al gate-urilor Pauli
pe qubiții fizici folosiți pentru codificare.
De exemplu, dacă considerăm codul de suprafață 3x3 care a apărut la sfârșitul lecției anterioare, atunci putem implementa gate-urile X și Z pe qubit-ul logic
codificat de acest cod combinând gate-urile X și Z împreună cu gate-urile identitate în tiparul sugerat
aici. Aceasta este o implementare transversală a acestor gate-uri deoarece fiecare dintre aceste operații individuale de gate
acționează doar pe un singur qubit din fiecare bloc de cod.
WEBVTT
Folosim doar gate-uri pe un singur qubit aici, deci este oarecum trivial în un sens, dar în orice caz, gadget-urile de acest fel nu vor cauza propagarea erorilor.
Acum, oricare dintre gate-urile individuale dintr-un gadget de acest fel ar putea eșua, și asta va introduce
erori, dar vom efectua întotdeauna corecția erorilor imediat după fiecare gadget. Și atâta timp cât rata de erori este
suficient de mică, codul de corectare a erorilor va corecta acele erori.
Și cum am spus, asta este întotdeauna posibil pentru operatorii Pauli pentru fiecare cod stabilizator.
Deși trebuie să identifici tiparul corect de gate-uri Pauli în gadget-uri pentru a implementa corect orice operație Pauli logică pe care o urmărești.
Pentru un alt exemplu care implică gate-uri cu doi qubiți. De data aceasta putem considera implementările transversale
ale gate-urilor C not. În special, pentru orice cod CSS, putem întotdeauna implementa un gate C not
între doi qubiți logici pur și simplu efectuând gate-uri C not pe perechile corespunzătoare de qubiți fizici.
Și asta satisface condiția de a fi transversal deoarece fiecare dintre aceste gate-uri C not individuale acționează doar
pe un singur qubit din fiecare bloc de cod. De exemplu, primul gate C not acționează doar pe qubit-ul din vârf
din fiecare bloc de cod. Al doilea gate C not acționează doar pe qubit-ul al doilea de sus și
așa mai departe. În acest caz, am putea avea o propagare a erorilor deoarece gate-urile C not propagă erorile și nu există
nicio modalitate de a preveni asta. Dar cheia este că propagarea erorilor nu se întâmplă niciodată în interiorul unui singur bloc de cod. De exemplu,
o eroare X ar putea apărea pe qubit-ul din vârf al blocului de cod superior chiar înainte ca gadget-ul să fie efectuat, iar primul C not
din gadget va propaga acea eroare la qubit-ul din vârf din blocul inferior. Dar cele două erori rezultante sunt
acum în blocuri de cod separate. Deci pașii de corecție a erorilor care au loc după gadget vor putea corecta acele erori individual, deoarece acele
erori afectează doar un singur qubit în fiecare bloc de cod.
Spre deosebire, dacă propagarea erorilor s-ar fi întâmplat în interiorul aceluiași bloc de cod, am putea fi în dificultate deoarece
propagarea erorilor transformă o eroare cu greutate mică într-o eroare cu greutate mai mare pe care codul nostru s-ar putea să nu o poată gestiona.
Această implementare nu funcționează pentru coduri non-CSS, dar atâta timp cât folosim un cod CSS, putem întotdeauna implementa gate-uri C not
transversal în acest mod. Și pentru un exemplu în plus, orice
gate Clifford poate fi implementat transversal pentru codul Steane. Și de fapt pentru orice cod de culoare, ceea ce este unul dintre lucrurile cu adevărat frumoase despre codurile de culoare
în particular, un gate Hadamard pe un qubit logic poate fi implementat efectuând gate-uri Hadamard individual pe
fiecare dintre qubiții fizici, iar un gate S logic poate fi implementat nu printr-un gate S pe fiecare qubit, ci printr-un gate
S dagger pe fiecare qubit fizic. Deci concluzia este că implementările transversale de gate-uri sunt inerent
tolerante la erori deoarece nu propagă niciodată erorile în interiorul unui singur bloc de cod, ceea ce dă pașilor de corecție a erorilor o șansă reală să corecteze
orice erori introduse sau propagate de gate-urile folosite pentru aceste gadget-uri. Deci asta e grozav și este o
modalitate cu adevărat simplă de a construi gadget-uri tolerante la erori și există diferite coduri care permit implementări transversale ale diferitelor gate-uri, cum ar fi
gate-urile T, dar din păcate este imposibil ca orice cod netrivial să implementeze un
set universal de gate-uri transversal, ceea ce este un fapt cunoscut ca teorema Eastin-Knill. În termeni mai tehnici, ce spune
este că atâta timp cât codul nostru are distanță cel puțin doi, setul de gate-uri care poate fi implementat transversal va genera în mod necesar un
set discret de operații până la o fază globală și, prin urmare, acest set nu este universal deoarece seturile universale de gate-uri
generează în mod necesar un număr infinit de operații. Nu voi explica demonstrația acestei teoreme care face uz de câteva
fapte de bază despre grupurile Lie și algebrele Lie, care nu sunt condiții prealabile pentru această serie. Dar ideea de bază este
că familiile infinite de operații transversale nu ne pot ține în mod necesar în interiorul spațiului codului deoarece diferențele minuscule
în operațiile transversale sunt bine aproximate de operații Pauli cu greutate mică pe care codul le detectează ca
erori. Deci suntem foarte mulțumiți când putem implementa gate-urile transversal. Dar pentru orice cod am alege, știm că
vom avea întotdeauna unele gate-uri pe care nu le putem implementa în acest mod. Și deci trebuie să căutăm gadget-uri alternative. Prin
teorema Eastin-Knill, știm că nu este posibil să implementăm un set universal de gate-uri cuantice transversal nici măcar
pentru un cod cuantic de corectare a erorilor de distanță 2. Deci trebuie să găsim alte modalități de a implementa gate-uri în mod tolerant
la erori, cel puțin pentru unele gate-uri. O modalitate bine-cunoscută de a face asta este prin utilizarea așa-numitelor magic states.
Pentru scopul acestei discuții, să ne amintim gate-urile S și T care sunt
gate-uri pe un singur qubit definite după cum se arată pe ecran. Să observăm și că, în primul rând, S este o operație Clifford
ceea ce rezultă din definiția noastră a operațiilor Clifford. Dar poți de asemenea verifica că conjugând o matrice Pauli cu S, obținem întotdeauna plus sau minus o altă
matrice Pauli. Și în al doilea rând, T nu este o operație Clifford. Și de fapt, dacă combinăm T cu Hadamard și C not, ambele
operații Clifford, obținem un set universal de gate-uri cuantice. Deci nu putem implementa un gate T
folosind doar operații Clifford și măsurători în baza standard. Dar putem de fapt implementa un gate T folosind
operații Clifford și măsurători în baza standard dacă în plus avem o copie a stării prezentate pe
ecran, care este gate-ul T aplicat unei stări plus.
Această stare se numește magic state, deși nu este unică în această privință.
Termenul de magic state este folosit și pentru a se referi la stări diferite care joacă un rol similar cu aceasta în variațiile acestei
scheme. De exemplu, circuit-ul prezentat aici face treaba. Și nu este prea greu de verificat
asta. Iată starea inițială cu sistemul de sus în dreapta. Și dacă aplicăm gate-ul C not și simplificăm, obținem
starea prezentată aici.
Deci dacă măsurăm qubit-ul de jos și obținem zero, ceea ce se întâmplă cu probabilitatea 1/2, nu efectuăm
gate-ul S și rezultatul este T aplicat lui S.
Și dacă măsurăm unu, ceea ce se întâmplă de asemenea cu probabilitatea 1/2 desigur, aplicăm gate-ul S și rezultatul net este
că rezultatul este din nou T aplicat lui S. Aceasta nu este singura modalitate de a face asta, apropo. Există alte circuit-uri cu aspect similar
care realizează aceeași sarcină, dar aceasta este una dintre modalități.
Acesta este un exemplu oarecum simplificat al ceva cunoscut ca teleportare cuantică a gate-urilor, la care am făcut aluzie în lecția 4, unde teleportarea este folosită
WEBVTT
nu pentru a trimite qubiți, ci pentru a aplica gate-uri. Conexiunea cu teleportarea poate să nu fie complet clară aici deoarece, cum am
spus, aceasta este o versiune simplificată, cu care ne putem descurca deoarece T este diagonal. Dar dacă ești interesat să
înveți mai multe, cuvintele cheie sunt teleportare cuantică a gate-urilor.
Și am putea face ceva similar pentru a implementa un gate S, unde de data aceasta singurele gate-uri de care avem nevoie sunt un gate C not și un gate Z împreună cu măsurătoarea,
ceea ce este util dacă nu avem o implementare transversală a unui gate S. Deci asta este interesant, dar nu este
complet clar că asta ajută cu adevărat. În cazul implementării gate-ului T, de exemplu, reușim
să aplicăm un gate T unei stări de intrare. Dar pentru a face asta, se pare că aplicăm un gate T unei stări plus pentru a obține un
magic state. Și situația este similară pentru implementarea gate-ului S. Ideea este că nu
trebuie neapărat să creăm mai întâi o stare plus și să aplicăm un gate T pentru a obține un magic state. Există alte modalități posibile de a obține această stare. Și în
special, putem face asta fără a trebui să ne îngrijorăm de propagarea erorilor în orice calcul la care lucrăm, deoarece magic states pot fi create
separat. Asta permite o implementare tolerantă la erori a unui gate T, pe care o voi descrie acum pe scurt.
Mai întâi, nu vom rula de fapt circuit-ul simplu cu doi qubiți prezentat, ci în schimb vom rula acest circuit folosind
qubiți codificați în orice cod de corectare a erorilor pe care îl folosim pentru implementarea noastră tolerantă la erori. Ceea ce înseamnă că
gate-urile unitare și măsurătorile sunt efectuate de gadget-uri tolerante la erori. Și asta înseamnă că avem nevoie și de
magic states codificate. Deci totul va fi tolerant la erori atâta timp cât putem obține
magic states codificate. Presupunem deja, de altfel, că avem un gadget tolerant la erori pentru gate-ul S. Dacă
am folosi codul Steane, de exemplu, am putea pur și simplu implementa gate-ul S transversal. Și pentru coduri pentru care asta nu funcționează, o opțiune este
să folosim mai întâi întreaga această schemă pentru a implementa un gate S în mod tolerant la erori și apoi să folosim acea implementare aici.
Deși aceasta nu este singura opțiune. Dar oricum, revenind la implementare, întrebarea importantă care rămâne este cum obținem
un magic state codificat dat că nu avem încă o implementare tolerantă la erori a unui gate T pentru a face asta
simplu? Și ideea cheie este că putem folosi un proces probabilistic pentru a crea magic states codificate. Și dacă nu
se dovedește să funcționeze, atunci e în regulă. Putem pur și simplu să aruncăm orice tentative eșuate și să încercăm din nou.
Și asta nu perturbă calculul pe care de fapt încercăm să îl efectuăm, deoarece crearea magic states se face
separat. O modalitate tipică de a face asta este printr-un proces cunoscut ca distilare de magic states. Și funcționează
astfel. Avem un anumit circuit cunoscut ca distilator. Introducem în acest distilator o colecție de magic states zgomotoase
și apoi măsurăm toate ieșirile mai puțin una. Și dacă condiționăm ca toate rezultatele măsurătorii să fie zero,
atunci ce se întâmplă este că ceea ce iese este un magic state mai puțin zgomotos, care poate fi apoi unul dintre qubiții introduși în
un alt distilator. Și procesul continuă până fie eșuăm pentru că unul dintre rezultatele măsurătorii este diferit de zero și încercăm din nou, fie avem un magic
state de calitate suficient de ridicată pe care o putem folosi în siguranță pentru a implementa un gate T în calculul care ne interesează.
Există diferite modalități cunoscute de a construi un distilator de acest fel, dar toate funcționează în principiu la fel, și anume că sunt decodoare pentru coduri stabilizatoare,
adică inversele circuit-urilor de codificare, ceea ce este frumos deoarece înseamnă că distilarul poate fi o operație
Clifford. Și în final, acest proces de distilare are loc de fapt la nivelul qubitului logic. Deci în realitate,
totul se face folosind gadget-uri pentru distilator și măsurători. Acest proces trebuie
să înceapă undeva. Dar atâta timp cât rata de zgomot nu este prea mare, este posibil să creăm magic states zgomotoase dar suficient de bune
pentru a-l porni. De exemplu, aplicând un gate T real zgomotos unui qubit într-o stare plus și apoi
codificând acel qubit. Deci aceea a fost o descriere de nivel foarte înalt, dar sper că ți-am dat o idee generală despre cum funcționează asta.
Este mult mai complicat decât implementarea transversală a gate-urilor, dar cu toate acestea, oferă o modalitate de a implementa un set universal de gate-uri cuantice
în mod tolerant la erori, în timp ce implementările transversale de gate-uri singure nu pot face asta. Se afirmă uneori
că costul folosirii magic states pentru a implementa gate-uri în mod tolerant la erori în aceste linii ar fi foarte mare,
cu marea majoritate a muncii ducând la distilarea magic states, iar rularea calculului efectiv este mai degrabă un
detaliu secundar. Dar asta nu este de fapt atât de clar și au existat analize detaliate care arată că această metodă
ar putea fi de fapt practică. Există câteva alte scheme cunoscute pentru implementarea tolerantă la erori a gate-urilor. Deformarea codului și comutarea codului sunt denumiri
asociate cu unele dintre aceste scheme, iar noi modalități continuă să fie dezvoltate și rafinate, dar nu voi descrie acele
metode în această lecție. Există o altă problemă importantă privind implementările tolerante la erori ale circuit-urilor cuantice și
aceasta privește pașii de corecție a erorilor înșiși. Deci nu este vorba de implementarea gate-urilor. Este vorba de efectuarea
corecției efective a erorilor. Problema este că dacă ne gândim la circuit-urile simple pe care le-am
văzut prima dată în lecția 14 pentru măsurarea generatoarelor stabilizatoare bazate pe estimarea fazei, constatăm că nu sunt
ele însele tolerante la erori deoarece ar putea cauza potențial propagarea erorilor în interiorul unui singur bloc de cod.
Asta revine la ideea că orice implică informație cuantică este susceptibil la erori și asta include circuit-urile care sunt ele însele menite
să corecteze erorile. Asta pare destul de problematic, dar există de fapt mai multe soluții cunoscute pentru această problemă. Voi menționa doar câteva
dintre ele, deși nu voi explica niciunul în detaliu. Și apropo, dacă ai impresia că computația cuantică tolerantă la erori este
complicată și există o mulțime de detalii de care să te îngrijorezi, atunci asta este cu siguranță de înțeles pentru că este adevărat. Există o mulțime de componente în mișcare
aici și intenția mea cu această lecție nu este să explic toate detaliile, ci mai degrabă să îți ofer o introducere de bază despre cum funcționează totul.
O metodă pentru corecția cuantică a erorilor tolerantă la erori este cunoscută ca corecția erorilor Shor, numită după Peter
Shor care a propus prima dată această metodă. Ideea este să efectuezi fiecare măsurătoare de sindrom folosind o așa-numită stare cat,
care este același lucru cu o stare GHZ când avem trei qubiți, dar poate fi generalizată la orice număr de qubiți care corespunde greutății generatorului stabilizator
pe care intenționăm să îl măsurăm. În particular, circuit-ul prezentat funcționează pentru măsurarea unui generator stabilizator. Și se poate
demonstra că această metodă nu cauzează propagarea erorilor în interiorul unui bloc de cod.
Ea necesită crearea stării cat înseși. Și pentru a o face să funcționeze fiabil în prezența erorilor și a gate-urilor potențial defectuoase, metoda de fapt
necesită să rulăm în mod repetat circuit-uri de acest fel și să facem inferențe despre locul unde ar fi putut apărea diferite erori în cursul
procesului. O metodă alternativă este cunoscută ca corecția erorilor Steane, propusă prima dată de Andrew Steane, și aceasta
WEBVTT
metodă funcționează diferit și funcționează doar pentru coduri CSS. În această metodă, nu efectuăm de fapt măsurătorile de sindrom pe stările cuantice codificate
din circuit-ul pe care încercăm să îl rulăm, ci în schimb propagăm intenționat erorile într-un sistem de spațiu de lucru
și apoi măsurăm acel sistem și detectăm clasic erorile. Această figură prezentată arată cum se face asta pentru erorile X, caz în care qubiții de spațiu de lucru
sunt inițial setați la o codificare a unei stări plus. Deci aceasta este practic o
implementare transversală a unui gate C not care ar trebui să nu facă nimic deoarece ținta este într-o stare plus. Dar dacă
ar exista erori X în qubiții de sus, se vor propaga în josul sistemului inferior și vor fi detectate. Există și o metodă similară pentru detectarea erorilor Z
care nu este prezentată aici. Există de asemenea o metodă înrudită cunoscută ca corecția erorilor Knill, propusă prima dată de Manny Knill,
și este bazată pe teleportare mai degrabă decât pe un C not transversal, ceea ce îi permite să funcționeze pentru coduri stabilizatoare arbitrare
și nu doar pentru coduri CSS.
Ultimul lucru pe care îl voi discuta în această lecție este o teoremă foarte importantă cunoscută ca teorema pragului. Iată o formulare
oarecum informală a teoremei. Ea spune că dacă avem orice circuit cuantic cu n gate-uri, unde n poate fi oricât de mare, atunci este
posibil să implementăm acel circuit cu acuratețe ridicată folosind un circuit cuantic zgomotos, cu condiția că nivelul de zgomot
este sub o anumită valoare prag independentă de n. Și mai mult, nu este prea costisitor să faci asta în
sensul că dimensiunea circuit-ului zgomotos necesar este de ordinul lui n înmulțit cu o putere constantă a logaritmului lui
n. Pentru a formula teorema mai formal este nevoie să fii specific cu privire la modelul de zgomot, ceea ce nu voi face în această lecție.
Poate fi de exemplu demonstrat pentru modelul de zgomot stocastic independent pe care l-am menționat mai devreme, unde erorile apar
independent în fiecare locație posibilă din circuit cu o probabilitate strict mai mică decât această valoare prag. Dar poate fi de asemenea
demonstrat pentru modele de zgomot mai generale, unde pot exista corelații între erori. Acum, acesta este un rezultat
teoretic, iar modul tipic în care este demonstrat nu se traduce neapărat în ceva ce am face de fapt în practică, dar este cu toate acestea o
teoremă foarte importantă în termeni practici. Și motivul pentru asta este că practic spune că nu există nicio barieră fundamentală în efectuarea
calculelor cuantice folosind componente zgomotoase.
Atâta timp cât rata de erori a acestor componente este sub această valoare prag, ele pot fi folosite pentru a construi circuit-uri cuantice fiabile de dimensiuni arbitrare.
O altă modalitate de a spune asta este că dacă teorema nu ar fi adevărată, e greu de imaginat că computația cuantică la scară largă
ar deveni vreodată realitate. Există o mulțime de detalii tehnice implicate în demonstrațiile formale ale acestei teoreme, pe care nu voi încerca să le
comunic. Dar voi încerca să explic ideea de bază la un nivel înalt. Și voi încerca de asemenea să conectez vag ideea de bază
cu ceea ce ne-am putea aștepta să se întâmple în practică. Deci să presupunem că acesta este circuit-ul nostru. Este același circuit de care
am vorbit pe tot parcursul lecției. Dar din nou, putem imagina că circuit-ul nostru este semnificativ mai mare și mai complicat decât acesta. Am dori să
implementăm acest circuit, dar toate componentele noastre sunt zgomotoase. Și presupunând că folosim modelul de zgomot stocastic independent
pur pentru simplitate, există o probabilitate P cu care erorile apar independent în fiecare locație posibilă.
Dacă circuit-ul ar fi semnificativ mai mare decât reciproca acestei probabilități P, atunci am putea fi destul de siguri că o
implementare directă a lui nu ar funcționa corect. Deci trecem prin toată munca de implementare a circuit-ului
în mod tolerant la erori, după cum am discutat până în acest punct al lecției, și ne punem întrebarea pe care am ridicat-o mai devreme, și anume facem lucrurile
mai bune sau le facem mai rele? Ei bine, dacă probabilitatea P care reprezintă probabilitatea de eroare pentru fiecare dintre componentele noastre este prea mare, atunci
asta nu va ajuta, la fel cum codul Shore de 9 qubiți nu ajută dacă probabilitatea de eroare este peste 3 și 3/4% sau cam așa.
În special, am făcut acum circuit-ul mai mare. Deci există multe mai multe locații unde ar putea apărea erori.
Totuși, dacă P este suficient de mic, asta va ajuta. Și ceea ce vom face efectiv este să reducem probabilitatea de eroare
pentru calculul logic pe care îl efectuăm. Deci să ne gândim la asta în
puțin mai mult detaliu. Și pentru a vedea ideile principale într-un cadru cât mai simplu posibil, să presupunem că folosim codul Steane de 7 qubiți pentru
corecția erorilor, care permite corectarea a până la o eroare per bloc de cod. Deci pentru ca o eroare logică
să apară în circuit-ul original, va trebui să avem cel puțin două erori care cad în același bloc de cod pentru implementarea noastră tolerantă
la erori.
Ținând minte că există o mulțime de moduri diferite de a avea două sau mai multe erori în același bloc de cod, se poate argumenta că probabilitatea unui
erori logice la fiecare locație din circuit-ul original este cel mult C * P ^ 2, unde C este un număr care depinde de cod și de
gadget-urile pe care le folosim. Dar în mod critic, nu depinde de dimensiunea circuit-ului original.
Deci dacă P este mai mic decât reciproca lui C, care este numărul pe care îl putem lua ca valoare prag, atunci aceasta
se traduce într-o reducere a erorii. Deci munca noastră grea în implementarea circuit-ului în mod tolerant la erori dă
roade. Totuși, această nouă rată de erori ar putea fi în continuare prea mare pentru ca întregul circuit să funcționeze corect. Deci trebuie să facem
mai mult. În practică, un lucru firesc de făcut în acest punct este să alegem un cod mai bun și gadget-uri mai bune pentru a reduce rata de erori
la un punct unde implementarea este probabil să funcționeze.
Teoretic vorbind, o modalitate simplă de a argumenta că acest lucru este posibil este să concatenăm. Cu alte cuvinte, ne gândim
la implementarea tolerantă la erori a circuit-ului original ca la un nou circuit logic. Și apoi îl implementăm în mod tolerant
la erori. Și apoi o facem din nou și din nou de câte ori avem nevoie. Și se dovedește că asta reduce eroarea
foarte rapid. Și astfel se demonstrează de obicei teorema pragului pe hârtie.
Îți voi oferi o idee foarte aproximativă despre cum scade rata erorilor, omițând multele detalii tehnice necesare pentru a
demonstra asta formal. Începem cu probabilitatea de eroare P pentru componentele noastre originale. Și dacă implementăm
circuit-ul în mod tolerant la erori, eroarea scade cu un factor de C * P. Dacă apoi tratăm implementarea noastră tolerantă la erori
ca un circuit logic și o implementăm în mod tolerant la erori, obținem o scădere similară în rata de erori. Dar
dacă ne gândim la rata de erori efectivă pentru circuit-ul original, constatăm că scade și mai mult, deoarece acum
înlocuim rata de erori P cu C * P ^ 2, deoarece aceea este rata de erori efectivă după primul nivel de implementare tolerantă la erori.
Specific, după puțin calcul algebric, constatăm că eroarea scade la CP
la cub * P. Și dacă o facem din nou, avem acum o rată de erori de CP ^ 7 * P. Și dacă
WEBVTT
continuăm să facem asta pentru un total de K niveluri, constatăm că eroarea scade dublu exponențial în K. Deci
nu trebuie să facem asta de foarte multe ori pentru a reduce rata de erori la un nivel extrem de mic.
Între timp, circuit-urile cresc în dimensiune, dar dimensiunea crește doar simplu exponențial în K deoarece cu fiecare
nivel de toleranță la erori, dimensiunea circuit-ului nostru crește cu cel mult un factor determinat de dimensiunea maximă a
gadget-urilor noastre. Și când totul este pus la un loc și se face o alegere adecvată pentru numărul
de niveluri de concatenare, obținem teorema pragului. Dar cum am sugerat deja, există o mulțime de detalii necesare pentru a face asta formal. Deci
care este această valoare prag în realitate? Ei bine, depinde de cod și de gadget-urile pe care le
folosim. Pentru codul Steane împreună cu distilarea magic states, este minusculă și probabil imposibil de atins în
practică. Dar folosind coduri de suprafață și gadget-uri de ultimă generație, s-a estimat că este în jurul valorii de 1%. Ceea ce nu este
rău. Și pe măsură ce noi coduri și metode sunt descoperite, ne putem aștepta în mod rezonabil ca aceasta să crească, în timp ce simultan
nivelul de zgomot din componentele pe care le construim va scădea. A atinge punctul în care
calculele cuantice la scară largă pot fi implementate în mod tolerant la erori nu va fi ușor și nu se va întâmpla peste noapte.
Dar această teoremă împreună cu progresele în codurile cuantice și în hardware-ul cuantic pe care le-am observat până în prezent
ne oferă optimismul de care avem nevoie pentru a continua să împingem înainte pentru a atinge acest obiectiv final de a construi un
calculator cuantic la scară largă tolerant la erori. Și aceasta este sfârșitul lecției și sfârșitul seriei. Eu
sincer sper că ai găsit valoare în serie și, dacă da, te rog să iei în considerare recomandarea ei unui coleg sau prieten.
De asemenea, asigură-te că verifici IBM Quantum Learning pentru cursuri și tutoriale suplimentare și abonează-te la canalul de YouTube al Qiskit
dacă nu ai făcut-o deja, ca să rămâi la curent cu lansările noastre viitoare de conținut. Mulțumesc că
ai urmărit.